[موسيقى]
مكرم ملقي سلام
مواليد 49 بدات الهوايه دي من خمسين سنه
او55 سنه وانا لسه ايه في بدايه حياتي
[موسيقى]
كلمني يا قمر فهمني يا قمر كلمني يا قمر
بدات انا ايه اجمع السينمات كلها طبعا
لافيش مش حاجه غاليه يعني حاجه رخيصه شويه
شويه لما عرفت النسخه الاصليه من النسخه
المعلقه النسخه درجه تانيه سبت شغل ايه
كنت عامل شركه ملاحه في السويس قفلت شركه
الملاحه
تخصصت لنفسي للسينما طبيعي وتجاره في نفس
الوقت ان انا بشتري وطبعا عشان اغطي
الشراء ابيع جزء الاصول طبعا جينا في
التمنينات بدات المنتجين يبيعوا الافلام
يعني منتجين يبيعوا ايه اصول الافلام
بتاعتهم
فبتبعيه المكاتب اللي هم كانوا موجودين
فيها بتبيع الورق وبتبيع النجت في الصور
الورق ما عجرفوش حاجه منهم الورقه لعبوش
حاجه منه الحبيبتي
[موسيقى]
ملك
ي انا عندي هنا البوستر
والصوره بتاعه الفيلم والافلام الوثائقيه
والدفتر بتاع السينما اللي هو بيحكي قصه
الفيلم هنا حوالي حوالي عشرين الف عفش
مختلف هم يطلعوا حوالي 300 فيلم
يا نهار اسود وهو كمان في حيطه يا مسافر
في الاول كان الطابعه التانيه بتاعه
القفيش الطابعه التانيه دي اخذتها من صبحي
فرحات مكتب مكتب صبحي فرحات يعني اللي هو
كان ايه بيعرض الافلام بتاعه عبد الوهاب
لما اخذت اخر حاجه صوت الفن لقيت فيهم
اربعه بص لعبد الوهاب الافلام الاولانيه
الاصل يعني سنه 36 وسنه 40
[موسيقى]
ملك فؤاد دول كانوا 4000
فيهم الملك فؤاد فيهم سعد زغلول النوادر
كلها
والمصور ده طلع مع الملك في رحلته لحد
اسوان فصور النيل وصور البلاد وصور دي
كلها ارشفه محافظات خدته
كله اغلب محافظات مصر وفي طبعا الشركات
والقطاع العام والقطاع الخاص ده انا معرفش
هو اللي هو اللي هو اصل المصدر بتاعه فين
ما اعرفش انا اشتريتهم بتوع الايه الفضه
اللي هم بيشتروا ايه بياخدوا فضه هو
النجده بيتباع بتاعه الفضه
[موسيقى]
تتامل فنجان
المقلوب سجون خد
نجتف للاذاعه المصريه من سنه 50 لسنه 64
لحد التلفزيون كان نجتف وهو ما كانش حد
علمه به لان شركه الشركه كانت بتصور
قفلت اماته وما اعرفش عن سيرته من واحد ما
كنتش عارف انه الاذاعه المصريه فهو فرجني
على صور محمد نجيب في
فلما خدته فرسته وعرفت انه ده الاذاعه
المصريه فبدات اوضاع انقله من بعد كده
عرضوا عليها في التلفزيون كلمني
[موسيقى]
مدير الاخبار فقلت له عندي كذلك الشريف
انا قررت ابيع المكان ده كله
هبيع كل كل المقتنيات لفرد واحد وحتى انا
لو قلت السعر كم مش هيعدل انصته مش هيعادي
العمر للوقت اللي انا ممكن كنت ارتاح فيه
الاربعين سنه الاخيره و30 سنه الاخيره
ضيعتهم في الجري بقى من هنا لهنا لهنا حتى
اي مبلغ مش هيعادل بس في النهايه انا كبرت
في السن فالقصه ان هي ايه يعني الحاجه دي
حرام انها ايه تضيع انا نفسي واحد ياخد
احتفظ بها او الدوله يحتفظ بها او دوله
يحتفظ بها بس
[موسيقى]
ازاي
يا عيني مش زي
[موسيقى]